die große aufregung beginnt mit ihm
harald nägeli der sprecher von zürich er
benutzt die stadt als seine leinwand je
öfter seine figuren auftauchen umso
aggressiver die reaktionen
er konnte
nägeli verlässt das land wird gejagt und
landet herz befürworter wie joseph beuys
im knast 20 sekunden öffentliche kunst
die sehr lange nachwirken
das ist ganz klar der zeitarbeit wird
politisch instrumentalisiert und das ist
ein schauplatz wo konflikt und streit
werden es ist aber das problem mit
autonomie foto kunz beschnitten wird und
wann sie anderen interesse zu stark
justine philip ursprung ist
kunsthistoriker an der eth zürich
er erinnert sich wie später die max bill
plastik das geschenk einer bank für
große unruhe sorgte es ist eine sehr
kontroverse und banker sind ist die
frage wem gehört der öffentliche raum
beim sind die staaten spaß kunst hat es
schwer in einem land wo alle mit
entscheiden wollen über kunst abstimmen
das ist schwierig sie lebt von der
überraschung von der anderen sicht auf
dinge
sie lebt davon gewohnheiten aufzubrechen
ein stück kunst hinzustellen das braucht
mut was keinen klaren nutzen hat gerät
schnell in politisches gezählt lieber
200 millionen für ein neues kunsthaus
als 600.000 für einen kran romanshorn
bis heute steht am bahnhof das
fabelwesen mock
was aussieht wie eine kinderfigur ist
ein kunstwerk und teil einer legende der
stadt angeblich ihren namen gab
mit den haaren von mock rettet der
kleine junge roman das dorf vor der
katastrophe so entstand der name romans
erfunden hat diese legende das
künstlerduo comcom mir ein trend merkt
okay die wissen nicht woher das kommt
kritik schicht woher der name und
intelligenter zimmert es bestehende
legende aus der region auf der bühne als
legende konstrukt und hände einer quasi
das macht man eine legende die die
romanshorner in aufruhr versetzte mir
fällt es noch identifizieren
mit dem ob das ist eine schweinerei
der öffentliche raum gehört allen er
spiegelt die gesellschaft reflektiert
den einzelnen über die anderen
die kunst ist da vor allem
projektionsfläche und schafft identität
will comcom do rock city der öffentliche
raum ist stark reglementiert funktional
die hinter der sicherheit muss möglichst
einfach zu warten sein und kommerziellen
interessen entsprechen
die kunst ist da erlaubt es brechen der
regeln wer darf schon den boden rot
anmalen wie damals 2005 die künstlerin
pipilotti rist in st gallen ein
kompromiss und dass sie das den knien
hat mir ein sehr schlauer stimmt aber
das ist ein anderes macht mich sehr froh
es braucht nicht nur die sicherheit
sondern vor allem auch mut zum risiko im
öffentlichen raum
und für alle die die kunst mögen die
kaum einer sieht empfehlen wir
romantikers drehscheibe in appenzell
nur wenn man drauf steht merkt man dass
etwas passiert
sonst dreht sich nur um sich selber im
grauen straßenbelag